(audience clapping)
- Gorgeous.
- Thank you so much.
- Oh my gosh!
- My friend Carly Mark, designed this.
She has a company called
"Puppets and Puppets".
It's very sculptural.
- It's very cool.
You walked out and I was like,
you were like a walking piece of art.
- Oh, that's the nicest
thing I've ever heard.
Well, I was watching you from
backstage thinking "What--
- All the horses
- A razzle, dazzle queen.
- I wore all the horses (laughs).
- I love every one of those horses.
- So people, normally, I mean,
you do look like a fashionista.
So people usually associate
you with New York,
but you're now in London, right?
- I am in London.
- Yeah.
- I married an English man,
and I stayed.
- Yeah.
Do you love it? I love London.
- I love it so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I find it, the architecture's beautiful.
The culture is, you know...
There's incredible history.
- [Kelly] History.
Yeah.
- There's incredible art.
The challenge I find is snacks.
- Ah, this is what I find
challenging on tour (laughs).
Yeah. See.
- That's--
- Nothing anymore--
- It's just different.
- It's different, firstly,
the range of snacks
is different.
- Yeah.
- If you're a very snack focused person,
it's hard.
- Yep, yep.
And secondly, everything
closes at like nine o'clock.
I'm from New York where--
- [Kelly] 24/7.
- 24/7.
This is an example, like I was depressed
at four in the morning in New
York, a couple of years ago,
got on Postmates and I
was able to order a burger
on two patties of ramen.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
At four in the morning.
- It's a beautiful city (laughing).
- It's a beautiful city.
I don't care about the,
I don't care about, you know,
the, like big buildings.
I don't care about,
you know, Central Park.
- [Kelly] It's the Ramen burger
- I care about the Ramen burger.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- So wait, so have you had
time to make your place?
Are you into like design and stuff?
You know, interior design
with your new place?
- I love it.
It's my passion.
I like to keep the...
Do you love interior design?
- I love it!
- It's like, to me it's--
- Nesting.
It's the most relaxing thing
to be able to make your space.
I mean, just your dressing
rooms here are iconic.
I walked in and I went,
I could live in here.
- That's my art department.
They're so great.
- Well, they're amazing.
But I try to be my own art department.
So I have, in the, I've
painted every wall.
I've muraled, I've, you know, made...
You guys are gonna get a little sense.
Gotten lots of stuff from vintage store.
- [Kelly] You're my sister.
She's creative like that.
She does it herself as well.
- [Lena] Those are my furry stools.
- [Kelly] Oh my Gosh!
- There's a woman named
Uzumaki who makes those
and people walk into the
kitchen and they scream
because they think I have
like three, sort of...
- Random animals?
- Random animals whose
hairs have been dyed
with Manic Panic, but
no, those are my stools.
- Do you have animals?
'cause, do they attack that?
- We do have,
We have two cats and two dogs.
And the funny thing is
our dogs are hairless.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
So our stools have hair,
but our dogs don't.
- I love you and your
husband, just so much already.
- Thank you so much.
And I love doing it.
And for a while, my husband was just like
"Yes, you do you, it's..."
But then I think I've empowered him
a little bit too much, and now--
- Oh well he's creative.
He's in the music world. Yeah.
- He is.
He's, there he is.
I miss him.
- So now he likes to be a part of it too.
- Now he likes--
- So are there battles of like, "Oh!"
- Well, Yes.
Like now he's having opinions
and we can't have men having those.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- He's like, So I live here too.
- Yeah. And I was like, that's
not what I signed up for.
I signed up for complete control.
- You are changing.
- That's exactly right.
- So you guys just celebrated this year,
your one year anniversary?
- We did.
- Congratulations.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- That's so cool.
- I didn't think I, I did not
ever think I'd get married.
I didn't think I was
gonna be a marriage person
but I'm enjoying it tremendously.
- Yeah. That's awesome.
I never thought I'd get married.
It didn't work for me.
But I, but I never, I never
thought I'd get married though.
I didn't.
And then it can be wonderful.
- Well what I love about you and this show
is how open you are
because so many people,
we know we live in a world
where people wanna be glossy and perfect.
And the fact--
- I am unfiltered.
- The fact that you come out here
and you're just like, yeah, marriage.
(blows raspberry) Not, not it, like.
- It's not for everyone. Yeah.
- No. And I, I think I had to obviously,
find someone very specific
who would be down to do marriage
the way that I wanna do marriage.
- Absolutely.
Yeah. I'm not against it. I
think it's a beautiful thing.
And I think it's so wonderful too.
Even like, you know, we have a,
a couple on today, later in the show,
and they're like older
and they just got married,
and they're like 80s and
90s and I'm just like,
that's beautiful.
I think it's beautiful.
- I think it's beau--
- But I do think we all,
because of how, you know,
we grew up, we all, our love
languages are different.
You have to find someone
that kind of matches you,
and you grow together,
I think that's important.
- And think it's beautiful
if you're getting to do it,
Like if you're doing
it in your 80s and 90s,
you're doing it on your own terms.
And I think so many of us were sold
a specific bill of goods about what,
sort of a heterosexual partnership
was supposed to look like.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think one of the
benefits of, you know,
having had a little
experience under my belt
before I got married was I was like.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was up for, living a
very different kind of life
where I was doing it on my own.
And then he just happened
to make that life better.
- Oh that's so cool.
You found something that
compliments you. That's amazing.
- And I hope I compliment him.
I keep talking about how he
has to follow all my rules
and how he compliments me.
- We know you're kidding. We know,
yeah.
- He's, okay thank you.
- We know you're being funny.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- So you have a podcast
called The C-Word.
Now, a lot of C words out
there, like which C word?
- It's a great question,
'cause there's so many fun C words
to choose from.
- There really are. Yeah.
- And some of them I really, in England,
there's a few that are really popular
that aren't as popular in the US.
- I know of one right now.
- You know of one right now?
- And they say it and I'm like
"Oh we're just freely saying that one."
- I know. We're just letting that one go.
And I know and I'm always kind of like
"Are we really allowed to do this?
"Okay, I'll jump right in."
- Yeah.
- But our word, our C word is crazy.
And it's about the way that women in,
often in the public eye
are perceived as crazy.
Whether it's by the press
or by fandoms or by culture at large.
And really trying to examine
why we ascribe certain labels to women.
I feel like, culturally right now,
we're having a moment
where we're revisiting
certain ways we've treated women.
Whether it's looking at the way
that we publicly dealt with Britney Spears
or certain starlets of the 2000s,
going "Actually the way that we spoke to
"and about this woman wasn't okay."
We've done an episode on Amy
Winehouse, Whitney Houston.
Iconic, important women,
who have also been labeled,
particularly by this
culture we live in, America,
as crazy or other.
And my partner who I do
it with, Alissa Bennett,
who's also my best friend, I'm very lucky.
She is, a historian and a cultural critic.
So she really gets in, and
digs in, and does the research.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then I try to take my experience
being publicly called crazy
and then we have a soup.
- Yeah, no I love that.
(audience clapping)
You know, it's interesting
even bringing up like, Whitney,
'cause that whole documentary
came out about her
and like a lot of us fans
didn't know all that background.
So that's the thing I think
we need to keep in our minds.
Like you don't know what people
are going through or have been through.
And then to label them that,
is so detrimental to them emotionally,
because you have no idea,
what has been put on them,
like from, since childhood, you know.
- That's so much what
the podcast is about,
is about looking at the fact
that these people have lived
big, full, complicated lives
and often been encouraged
to keep a lot of that secret
because of the way that we want our--
- 'cause they're a product.
- To someone.
Yeah.
- That's,
and you would know about,
I mean you started in this business young.
- Never. I've never been there,
myself.
- You've never known
what that feels like.
- No.
Never had anyone treat me like a product.
- No. So that's, that's the thing is also
being treated like a product
makes you wanna push back and push out
and then kind of,
"misbehave".
But where does that really come from?
- Yeah.
- We just started our season
with a two-parter on Lindsay Lohan,
can't wait for this
Netflix Christmas movie.
I am gonna be the first person
who watches Lindsay
Lohan's Christmas movie.
I'm just gonna be--
- I love Christmas movies. First of all.
- I love Christmas movies.
I love Lindsay Lohan.
I'm gonna be stuffing my face
with popcorn and cheering.
- I think that's the thing too,
I tell artists on The
Voice that I work with
'cause there's a lot of young
ones that I work with usually
and I'm like, quit, like do
not aim to please everyone.
Like it's never going to work.
Like do you, There's gonna
be an audience for it
and there's gonna be
a whole mess of people
that are like not vibing
with you. And that's okay.
Like, but I think people think
they have to, they wanna
be all to all people
and it's, that's exhausting.
No one can do that.
- No.
- Yeah.
- There's an amazing Nina Simone quote,
and I'm gonna butcher it slightly.
- Can't wait.
- But, you're excited for me to just but--
- Yeah.
- But it's a beautiful quote, which is
you are, you lose everything you've got
trying to give everyone what they want.
And--
- Yeah.
- When I heard that and then butchered it,
it really spoke to me in
a deep and profound way.
- Yeah.
- And I think,
those people are so
lucky that they have you,
to be that guide for them.
They're so lucky that they have you,
someone with experience.
Because if I'd had sort
of an older person,
older woman with experience telling me,
You know what?
- I wish I would've had that.
- "This is what it's gonna look like."
I think my life would've,
I mean I'm very happy with where I am,
but I also think that--
- My 20s would've been a lot smoother.
- I would've spent a lot less time
crying into that Ramen burger.
- Yeah. (audience laughing)
I just, crying in
general. Yeah. I was like.
So you're also highlighting strong women
in your new movie
"Catherine Called Birdy".
So what is "Catherine Called Birdy"?
- "Catherine Called Birdy" is a movie
that's based on my favorite
book from childhood
which was called, shocker,
"Catherine Called Birdy".
(Kelly laughing)
And it's about--
- Where did you come up with the title
for the movie?
- I know!
And it's about a young woman,
a 14 year old in 1290 Medieval England
who is living her life,
loving her childhood,
getting to kind of have that like,
rough and tumble experience
of being a little kid,
and then gets her period and
her parents basically decide
it's time to marry her off.
And it's about her fight to
maintain her independence.
But it is a comedy.
- Yeah, I love that.
- And so--
- I would've just never told anyone
I started my period. (chuckles)
- Well she tries that,
- Yeah.
- And it doesn't work.
And so it's that story,
the story of her kind of trying
to maintain her independence
and her sense of self,
and really coming up against the idea
of what women can and can't do.
And I think what's funny
is it takes place a thousand years ago,
but, almost a thousand years ago.
But there's a lot in
there that still feels.
- Relevant
- Very relevant because we
still live in a culture,
as we discussed, that puts a lot of very,
specific constraints and demands on,
not just its young
women, its young people.